all right we start tonight with breaking
news
and details about the investigation into
this horrific tragic
florida high school shooting now the 19
year old gunman nicholas cruz
he has now confessed to slaughtering 17
innocent people
and wounding at least a dozen others now
cruz is also telling investigators
details of the sinister attack
he shot students in the hallway he fired
into five separate classrooms
and crews also confessed to authorities
that he had extra ammunition in his
backpack
now we're also learning disturbing new
details of missed warning signs
in what is now one of the worst mass
shootings in american history
all of the red flags were there but
tragically
nicholas cruz was able to commit this
heinous act
now the fbi is in fact confirming
tonight that in september
a youtube user with the name nicholas
cruz
spelled the name the same way as the
shooter was reported to the bureau
for writing quote i'm going to be a
professional school shooter
the man who reported the comments says
that the fbi visited him
the following day but the bureau was
saying today that it could not be
determined
the time the location and actual
identity of who posted the comment
now our own catherine herridge as she
noted earlier today all the fbi would
have had to do is trace the ip address
which is a routine practice to determine
the location of the individual
for some reason it didn't happen in this
case now the mayor of broward county is
saying that nicholas cruz
was being treated at a mental health
clinic but stopped seeking treatment
more than a year ago
and authorities are describing his
social media posts as beyond disturbing
just take a look at some of these
pictures you can see the suspect he's
seen
posing with guns and knives and even
dead animals
and former classmates of cruz say he was
a loner he was obsessed with firearms
he liked to show off pictures of all of
his weapons
now the miami herald is reporting that
crews had been suspended for fighting
and having ammunition in his backpack
and cruz was then later expelled for
disciplinary reasons
and was attending a school in broward
county for at-risk students
crews also had problems at home both
parents adopted him
and his brother are dead his mother
passed away in november
the suspect was staying with a friend's
family and there were also reports of
nicholas cruz having ties to a
florida-based white supremacist group
but law enforcement said earlier today
that they haven't seen any
of those connections we'll continue to
monitor what's also very troubling
tonight is how
students are describing their former
classmate
now this is what they say about the
shooter nicholas cruz let's watch
he definitely had a just something a
little off about him but it was just
more or less that he was aggressive
and and quiet and shy about it
when he got aggressive personality was
like very
like different he was a bit off he uh he
would
like curse randomly in the middle of
lunch you know he would just like scream
out random curse words and
like he always just seemed a little bit
off you know like just something was
wrong with him that it was a lot of like
uh crazy stuff that he did uh just
not right for school he got kicked out
of school multiple times for this kind
of stuff honestly a lot of people were
kind of saying that it was going to be
him stuff like that we actually we threw
all kids through drugstore like that
saying that he wasn't the one that
screwed up the school but it turns out
you know everyone predicted it it's it's
that's crazy
now just like with other mass shooters
there were signs there were
warnings of mental social emotional
problems
but all the pieces were never put
together to prevent this tragedy from
happening
and like with many other shootings and
terrorist attacks nicholas cruz was
telegraphing his attentions all over
social media
now aside from the obvious fact that
anyone that would
commit these horrible acts of evil and
violence are completely deranged
the one commonality between the gunman
and parkland florida
to southerland texas to the church in
south carolina
sandy hook virginia tech are mental
health issues and mental illness
during an address to the nation earlier
today the president offered his deepest
condolences
and he highlighted this issue of mental
health let's take a look
we comfort the grieving and the wounded
and we hurt for the entire community of
parkland florida
that is now in shock and pain and
searching
for answers to law enforcement
first responders and teachers who
responded so bravely in the face of
danger
we thank you for your courage we are
committed to working
with state and local leaders to help
secure our schools
and tackle the difficult issue of mental
health
later this month i will be meeting with
the nation's governors and attorney
generals
where making our schools and our
children
safer will be our top priority
it is not enough to simply take actions
that make us
feel like we are making a difference
we must actually make that
difference profound words from the
president saying
it's not enough to feel better it's got
to make a difference now he's also
the president is planning to visit
parkland florida and offer comfort and
support to the community
details have not yet been finalized also
predictably within hours
democrats the liberal media they race as
they always do to politicize a tragedy
and try to blame believe it or not
president trump and republicans
let's take a look step up
be a man and talk about it and stop
thinking about the nra
and your next uh campaign donation just
stop
everyone knows what you're doing and
it's time
that does it for us this morning
stephanie rule picks up the coverage
right now thanks so much mika thanks joe
and to marco rubio
you don't have to step up and be a man
step up and be a human
the words of constellation talk about
mental health
are simply not enough they must be
followed by real action
the president has to lead or get out of
the way
the people have got to say enough is
enough this
we're not continuing with all these
massacres
and we've got to have the
representatives of the people
in the halls of government respond to
that
this has happened with republican
administrations under democratic
administrations but what you see there
it's shameful it's disgusting
but it's not surprising because it's so
predictable it happens every single time
there is a shooting
hollywood celebrities they were also
quick to post their hateful messages
of course aimed at the president
republicans on twitter let's start with
chelsea handler tweeting quote
they have to elect candidates that are
not funded by the nra in november
we have an opportunity to elect
candidates who won't allow kids to go to
school and get shot
it's disgusting how many times this has
happened and republicans do nothing
you all have blood on your hands bette
midler another school shooting this in
florida
congrats to the spineless cowards who do
nothing to help us stem this horrific
epidemic
in congress and director adam mckay
posted
normal person oh my god kids are being
killed in schools churches concerts
let's do something
republican congressman kids are being
killed in schools and churches and
concerts
let's not do one single thing hashtag
blood on your hands at gop
and at nra author stephen king writes
broward county broward school shooting
there will be prayers from blabbermouth
don pence and the grinch
and their right wing cohorts there will
be no call for any sort of sane gun
regulations
now that sadly is the left solution
every single time this happens
they rush the judgment they want to
point fingers and blame and use
all kinds of vicious horrific rhetoric
it never accomplishes anything
now they shouldn't be what these
tragedies are about here
you have people rolling out the same old
tired talking points and political
arguments
you know liberals they start blaming the
weapon that the shooter used in this
case an ar-15 but
if they want to ban ar-15s and these
madmen they will use something else we
saw that at virginia tech
where a gunman used a pistol and killed
32 people
look let's get let's get to solutions
tonight i have been in radio
for 30 years of my life i've been now
this is my 23rd year at the fox news
channel
i know all of the talking points and i
know it's all just noise and it's not
going to solve the problem
here's a simple truth you're not going
to change people's
minds with a political debate especially
as it relates to the second amendment i
am a strong supporter of the second
amendment
my mind's not going to be changed i've
thought this through all these years in
my life
and i doubt i can change the minds of
any of these hollywood liberals
and the anti-second amendment crowd the
problem this country
is facing right now is school safety now
we can keep repeating the same talking
points and talking over each other again
and again and again
after something like this happens or
maybe it's trying to actually
find a solution to this problem the
children of this country
deserve to be protected they deserve
safe schools as the president said no
child no teacher
should ever be in danger in an american
school we can all agree on that
no parent should have to fear for their
son or daughters
when they kiss them goodbye in the
morning now i want to lay out a solution
that i think
is not political and frankly i believe
any reasonable person can agree on
this is about the safety and security of
students and children
in our schools and every single school
in the country
needs immediately a comprehensive threat
assessment
done by law enforcement professionals
every school has a unique situation
and for those that will say oh uh where
are we going to get the money for this
well i would argue that it's probably
more than likel likely
local police local fbi would be happy to
help schools
figure out the best plan of action to
protect these kids and keep them safe
now you're going to have to secure the
perimeter of every school
all points of entry must be secure you
got to make
sure that there is a system that
controls who is going in and out of the
building
and in addition to that you'll need a
strong physical
security presence and you can start by
hiring
trained armed former or retired police
officers
trained armed former retired armed
military veterans in other words
let's give our kids the same security
that most politicians that they get
let's give them the same protection that
actors actors and actresses get
on the red carpet when they're at the
oscars and pretty much everywhere else
they go
we have plenty of retired officers
plenty of trained professionals
plenty of trained military guy they can
conceal their weapons
but their very presence also with a
strategy
strategic plan that is properly
implemented will bring about a profound
change i know they're probably
detractors out there they're going to
say but
but sean parkland florida high school
they had an armed security guard
okay here's the thing the school has 3
000 students
it's one of the biggest campuses in
florida you're going to need more than
one person to properly assess and deter
any potential threat at a facility that
large
we need enough people to protect every
single building
every point of entry and the entire
perimeter
now some of you will argue okay this is
going to cost money you're right my
answer is yes but is it not worth every
penny
so that we never ever have to turn on
our tvs like yesterday
and see this unfold ever again like what
happened in parkland
now here's another point about the plan
now we already know it works
i broadcast from new york city and post
911
you cannot enter a single office
building without a work id
i have a radio building i enter i have a
tv building i enter and if you're a
visitor in
any of these buildings you have to
present a valid identification or else
you're not getting in
and you have to be vouched for by people
that have been secured and already in
the building or work in the building
every student can have their own valid
id before entering the school
and also where needed metal detectors
which have already proven to be
effective
in some schools in the country here's
the bottom line we're at a crossroads
it's time to either step up do our job
create
school safety that will work for these
kids give them the same
safety our politicians actors actresses
and famous people get
and instead of you know bringing out the
same old talking points and trying to
score cheap political points
and trying to outdo each other with the
same arguments same attacks nobody's
minds being changed
maybe for once we could solve the
problem and this should be
all about solutions now i'm not saying
this applause this plan is flawless
nothing is ever going to stop a hundred
percent of these things from happening
there is evil in the hearts of other
people unfortunately in this world
but why wouldn't we try to do every
single thing we can do in this case
to prevent these tragedies from
occurring and
make them less deadly if in fact they do
happen
here's a simple test and a question for
everybody tonight i think they can ask
themselves
if god forbid you ever found yourself in
any type of administrative building
and that building has an active shooter
would you prefer
to know that there are trained armed
retired
military and police already on site
to give you a fighting chance would you
want to know that there was a complete
threat assessment
security assessment on that building
that was completed
my guess is you probably would now
here's our final point
democrats they say gun control leads to
less violence well if that's the case
i'd like to explain why cities with the
highest murder rates
have the strictest gun control and are
run by democrats look at these stats
about the number of murders in 2016. all
of these cities have democratic mayors
and have been run by liberals for years
yet their crackdowns on the second
amendment it has done nothing to stop
violence
liberals also don't want you to know
about these shocking statistics
during the obama presidency over 3 900
murders in his home
adopted a town of chicago and more than
eighteen thousand people who were shot
in chicago
just during the last six years of his
presidency now did you remember
hearing this kind of outrage and blame
by the left
about the out of control violence that's
one american city
and liberals also love to say that
giving people the right to carry doesn't
prevent crime
the figures say otherwise let's take a
look at some of the charts given to us
by
author more guns less crime john lott jr
from the crime prevention research
center
the chart shows violent crime before and
after right to carry laws were enacted
in the u.s
and as you can see having more citizens
armed lead to
it leads to a decrease in violent crime
here's another graphic
on murder rates before and after right
to carry laws were put into place
also in the u.s murders have plunged as
a result
and as john lott jr points out as more
people carry guns
you see further drops in both of those
statistics
all right a lot to absorb the answer is
we got to protect our kids
we don't need to tune into what we saw
yesterday ever again
let's start solving the problem